ladies and the clown je suis très
heureux de vous parler d'un produit
aujourd'hui que j'ai eu il ya pas
longtemps en main c'est ce produit-là de
one place ce sont d'aller one plust
bouloc bullets crois que c'est mieux les
one pelote les one place je vais y
arriver bullets boulotte boulez chez
plus à prononciation bon c'est pas grave
wireless
ce qui est super cool ces centres est
regardée
[Musique]
ce fonds ces petits écouteurs intra
auriculaires alors c'est un format qui
z'ont pas trop france parce que vous
avez un scène avec un tour du cou et que
le tour de cou n'a pas la cote en france
pour les casques par contre ce cas ce
que là franchement il est vraiment très
très bien et notamment pour son
positionnement tarifaire alors ce qu'on
va faire c'est je vais vous le présentez
vous expliquer comment il marche c'est
par un tout nouveau produit il a déjà
été présenté l'année dernière mais moi
je ne connaissais pas et comme je taise
de plus en plus d'audio je trouve
vraiment franchement intéressant il
coûte 69 euros à quelque chose près de
là vous verrez si vous bougez vous ai
mis un lien en bas dans la description
mais pour son prix il fait franchement
beaucoup de choses et il est vraiment
bien la première chose je vous montrais
packaging parce qu'une fois de plus le
tube en place a fait un truc
extraordinaire
moi j'adore tout simplement le boulot
est fait par une place au niveau du
packaging
en règle générale je trouve que ils ont
vraiment un très très bel univers de
marques qui se valorisent avec des
produits qui sont vraiment hyper cali et
quand on ouvre la boîte on se rend
toujours plus contre regarder up
bondissent colas un peu classique
je vole ur là normalement ici vous avez
ça donc ça vous le voyez apparaître ici
et de l'autre côté vous retrouvez le
slogan de la marque petite pochette
c'est hyper hyper qu'ailleurs regarder
cette dans cette ouverture vous ouvrez
comme ça et là vous avez vos petits en
bout et vos petites ailettes c'est
franchement hyper bien il faut vraiment
pouvoir trouver la bonne dimension
d'embouts qui correspond à votre oreille
à votre morphologie ce nom c'est pas
hyper conforme il ya le choix et se soit
posé comme ça directement d'un 'package'
je trouve ça vraiment cool alors ici
vous avez cette petite étude moi je
trouve sympa les fous qui est aimanté
tout fout le camp en tous cas ce garder
là vous avez petite partie éventé et
bien évidemment pour le recharger parce
que oui il se recharge en usb type c'est
d'ailleurs la recharge vous l'avez ici
sur le casque c'est franchement hyper
sympa donc vous rechargez avec la dass
charge ça va assez vite en à peine dix
minutes vous gagnez vos musiques et une
charge complète vous avez huit heures
musique donc ça franchement de ce point
de vue là c'est cool et en plus j'aime
bien ce petit et huile je trouve très
mignon j'aime bien leur couleur vous
pouvez tout ranger là dedans vous mettez
vos petits écouteurs vous mettez votre
chargeur tout ça là dedans et vous
glisser dans votre poche
ensuite deux scouts et là vous avez vos
écouteurs alors il faut venir enlever à
cette petite partie et regardez même à
l'intérieur vous avez le message fri you
mieux écrite au reader wi fi à offense
voyez avec l'accent franchement ça
envoie du bois
vous venez tirer et là vous trouvé vos
petits écouteurs qui sont situés à
l'arrière est ici vous avez votre guide
d'utilisation et votre dit de sécu qui
viennent se glisser à l'intérieur donc
voyez même au niveau de la boîte au
niveau du packaging s'est complètement
optimisé moi c'est vraiment ce que
j'aime dans l'univers cette marque c'est
qu'effectivement tout est complètement
optimisé bien positionné et d'un point
de vue marketing
même au niveau du packaging c'est
franchement énorme lavoyer user's guide
il vous le marque c'est franchement bien
fait
la question c'est qu'est ce qu'on peut
faire avec ce petit truc alors faire
plein de choses
la première chose qu'on peut faire avec
c'est déjà se le mettre autour du cou
et comme ça vous êtes beau vous êtes
belle c'est très sympa c'est la classe
au-delà de ça vous allez pouvoir bien
évidemment écouter de la musique
l'utiliser pour répondre au téléphone ça
c'est aussi cool et l'utiliser avec
google assistant on retrouve vraiment
les éléments de marque notamment avec le
le petit fils rouges d'alors existe soit
en rouge soit en moi mais d'un point de
vue design s'est dit alors la seule
chose que je suis pas persuadé en tout
cas en europe est certainement en france
que ça fonctionne ce système de tour du
cou d'ailleurs dit moi je sais que c'est
très nombreux et très nombreuses à me
regarder en france mais pas seulement
dans le monde entier alors vous qui êtes
en dehors de france
est ce que ce système de tour du coup ça
marche chez vous est ce que c'est un
truc que vous pourriez acheter à ce que
c'est un truc que vous avez déjà acheté
et est-ce que vous
et bien d'autres ont préféré le trou
ailleurs laisse où vous avez beau petits
écouteurs pas fiables à rien du tout
marc coma tous arba parce que je suis
très curieux parce que je sais qu'en
france c'est pas trop un truc qui
fonctionne donc là vous avez ce petit
système ça vous venez de mettre dans
votre oreille comme ça rendez-vous le
positionner comme ça hop ça vous le
poussez intérieur et ça ça veut dire ce
qu'elle est là là alors je vois pas très
bien si on le voit ça se calme vraiment
dans l'oreille
le truc est vraiment intéressant parce
que ça permet vous voyez alors ça dépend
on n'a pas tous nm forme d'oreille mais
comme ça vous voulez vraiment le cas les
à l'intérieur de votre oreille alors
après vous le révéler comme vous voulez
mais ça c'est vraiment cool parce que ça
ait vraiment au maintien ce qui fait que
déjà le fait que ce soit posé autour du
cou
vous n'avez pas un truc qui va
pendouiller william fils il reste
vraiment suspension dont ça c'est cool
et en plus de ça ça bouge pas donc vous
pouvez aller dehors pouvait courir c'est
vraiment bien ça vous approchent le
micro assez près de la bouche lorsque
vous allez passer des coups de fil ça
c'est aussi franchement cool aurait
voulu régler comme vous voulez en
fonction du pull par-dessus plus bas
plus haut vous avez accès aux boutons
volume au bouton pour venir décrocher
très facilement et une fois que vous
avez trouvé vos mouvements book vous
avez bien paramétré par rapport à votre
oreille je trouve ça bien en plus de ça
vous avez quand même une vraie belle
isolation passive c'est-à-dire ça vous
bougez bien les oreilles alors c'est pas
la haye où sont bruyants n'a pas du tout
son nez sans casser coûte 69 euros dont
fera pas du tout réduction de bruit mais
par contre une fois que vous avez dit là
déjà ça vos copains qui peut l'extérieur
en gros ça vous bouche les oreilles et
ça c'est déjà pas mal
autre truc qui est marrant c'est que là
c'est aimante et donc hop vous les
prenez disposent ils restent devant vous
comme ça ça évite qu'ils se baladent de
tous les côtés c'est très pratique mais
il ya une fonction supplémentaire était
aussi très très très intéressante c'est
que lorsque vous écoutez de la musique
lorsque vous les enlevez la musique ne
se coupe pas par contre vous les prenez
histoire aimante et la musique s'arrête
c'est radical et c'est très pratique
je vais vous mettre un petit morceau
d'un véri album des foo fighters que
j'aime bien vous allez voir là alors
vous allez pas forcément entendre le
forsc de toute façon je n'ai pas le
droit de vous lui même musique maestro
son envoi du sont donc là hop on entends
je prends la musique s'arrête
directement ça c'est franchement un
point de détail mais c'est très bien
lorsque vous n'êtes pas vendre dans le
train quel contrôleur qui avait pris pas
vous prenez vous poser c'est terminé ça
vous embête plus donc ça c'est
franchement pas très positif d'un point
de vue à peut-être de l'intérieur on a
du bluetooth 4.1 on a le
le qualcomm a pété x en gros ça vous
servira à avoir un son de meilleure
qualité et vous avez ce qu'ils appellent
les nervis tube alors l'énergie tube on
va dans la même direction c'est à dire
optimiser le son pour que en gros vous
ayez une qualité sonore complètement
maximiser ce qui est très intéressant
c'est que dans ces petits écouteurs à 69
euros
on a quand même des belles techno et qui
vous permettent de profiter d'un son de
qualité alors justement parlons-en du
son moi je trouve que le souhaitent un
peu trop médium un peu trop médium est
un peu trop criard un peu trop agressif
c'est ce qui m'a un peu dérangé lorsque
je l'écoutais après je lui paramétrer
mon équaliseur et en venant gratter un
petit peu alors sans forcément faire des
réglages de fou j'ai réussi à voir un
show que je trouve vraiment cool et ça
permet vraiment de profiter complètement
des qualités sonores de ce petit casque
dites vous bien que ce truc là
une fois que vous avez bien paramétrer
votre audio vous allez optimiser votre
équaliseur franchement il fait un super
boulot
regardez ça c'est mon petit réglage dans
des co leaders dans apple musique j'ai
cassé au niveau de 910 r c'est vraiment
là le quota criard ce qui fait un peu
mal aux oreilles vers 1 910 r 1 kg 1 kg
5 ça fait mal vous ne touchez pas à 4 kg
vous ne touchez pas ou alors très très
légèrement à 230 kg les fréquences entre
250 de 130 kg qui vont être vraiment
sûrs du grave j'ai monté un peu le 60
hertz alors très clairement ce cas ce
que là il va pas développer une
soixantaine mais savoure ajoutera un peu
de sensation de basse j'ai monté
légèrement les fréquences très aigu sur
le 14000 hertz
j'ai pas touché l'amplification des
bases parce que je trouve vraiment que
ça venait atténuer les restes mais vous
restez juste comme ça en gros l'idée
c'est que fait une petite courbe en v
vous casser un peu le médium vous restez
un petit peu les extrémités et la
profiter vraiment du son qui est à mon
avis complètement maximiser et une fois
que vous avez fait ça la qualité est
franchement hyper hyper bluffant parce
que vous avez inspectent qui est comment
dire très équilibré vous avez des graves
qui sont présents alors on n'est pas sur
un truc de fou un de toute façon voyez
bien qu'avec des petits appareils comme
ça on va pas développer des graves très
puissant néanmoins c'est franchement
bluffant surtout pour le prix c'est ça
qui est quand même assez hallucinant les
médiums sont corrects pas trop brouillon
ça reste franchement correct les aigus
sont présents on n'a pas une finesse
incroyable on n'est pas non plus ce sont
des des appareils complètement fou
furieux mais il faut vraiment le gros
situer par rapport à son prix ça reste
quand même très bluffant
en plus de ça vous avez un gros volume
sonore alors le but attention une fois
de plus je le dis ne poussez pas à fond
ne pas avoir d' écoute prolongée
beaucoup trop fort vous allez vous
rendre complètement sourd et c'est pas
du tout le but de la manoeuvre mais par
contre ce qui est vraiment bien c'est
que vous avez quand même rouge satrape
les yeux c'est que vous avez quand même
un gros gros gros volume sonore si vous
voulez profiter d'un morceau il envoyait
un peu plus de steak vous pouvez c'est
vraiment hyper agréable
on n'est pas du tout sûr des trouvailles
en laisse wang plus pour nous sortir en
2019 des trouvailles en laissent ils
vont effectivement justifier il ya pas
très longtemps les ans on a retiré la
prise jack
au niveau d'une vanne pucistes et ça
nous permet de travailler sur des
écouteurs sans fil
ils vont aller plus loin et je pense que
ce système là va disparaître tout
doucement pour arriver sur des baux
trouvailles en laye savoir ce qui va
arriver cette année je pense que ça va
être très intéressant et s'en va ce type
de prêt notamment au niveau de la sortie
du one + 7 qui aura lieu au mois de mai
cette année dont je vous invite bien
évidemment à vous abonner parce que on
va en parler on testera tout ça aura
tout ça très près dès sa sortie donc ça
ça va être franchement hyper cool en
attendant dites moi ce que vous en
pensez comment vous les trouvez vous
c'est gens prennent bien le nom que je
le mange pas assez le one + bullet au
wireless comment voulez trouver
intéressant par intéressant est ce que
le fait d'avoir un tour de cou ceint
truc bloquant pour vous on voit pas en
france en tout cas des gens avec des
tours du coup comme ça on n'en voit pas
beaucoup je sais pas si vous ça peut
vous bottez oui non en tout cas si vous
intéresse s'il vous plaît je peux vous
dire vous serez pas déçu du tout au
niveau du rapport qualité prix 69 euros
franchement fait plein de choses avec un
très très bel objet la qualité est là le
volume et là une fois de plus si vous
bougez vous a mis le lien en bas dans la
description
je vous invite bien évidemment aller
consulter ma paire east qui s'affiche
par ici par là où par là dans lequel
j'ai testé pas mal de casque
dernièrement les derniers galaxie buzz
castaing réduction de bruit de microsoft
casse car ils sont bruit de sony le wh1
ericsson 3 pas mal de choses qu'on va
continuer j'aime beaucoup l'audio
c'était mon premier job ses techniciens
sont donc que l'audio j'en ai eu un peu
de tous les côtés on restera
probablement très prochainement un
casque sennheiser en balade ouverte
plein plein plein de choses à dire donc
ça c'est hyper cool voilà où je vous
embrasse
à très bientôt pour les sens et vous
ciao